try to lose the the tension shouldn't be
tension in your body no tension in your
body okay so I go I feel it just
easy feel
look my last stance not
here okay let's
try use curves
curves breathe breathe relax relax
a she moves your
sword she moves your
sword no you're picking it
up see and see how it gets horizontal on
you do it do it again
again
right release and relax at the end right
let her move it let her move it no got
horizontal on you
right
better
tension no way tense it's horizont
a tense it's horizontal your what I mean
by horizontal is your tip isn't tracing
on the ceiling it's tracing on the north
wall yield to
it yeah it's so
horizontal you got to dip the tip you
got to dip the tip then it can be then
it will come around on the ceiling you
have to stop fighting him he's going to
push down you dip the
tip get the tension out of
there you got to get the tension out of
your body
same thing dip the tip when she pushes
down you're going to yield by dipping
the tip letting her push it down uh
don't run from her
though that's that's another kind of
seeking control is I'm not going to let
her push me I'm going to be ahead of it
she you're going to yield to her as she
[Applause]
pushes and then release
[Music]
relax now you're ahead to her
[Applause]
we don't need the
pause holy what are these baby
forces change R roles I'm not going to
learn every anything if I reduce it to
nothing
right oh come on same thing
same thing let him let him push on it
you
yield
better and settle at the end don't be in
a hurry to get out of that stance you're
falling out
of yield
yield watch you watch what that tension
is doing to you you're starting to lean
to the
left just sink down
okay and none of you none of you four
had the stance I
had this this stance
is
here
here okay not
here I'm going to drop and hit
low that's his wrist right he's pushing
my sword down on here
there's enough power on it just relax
okay okay it's just the
wrist that's all I'm cutting
through boom okay that thing's gone
right I I need to be over here like this
so as she as she pushes down go slow I
lower to keep it and I
yield there it is right there okay
so slow
I I push she push I yield I drop because
if I don't drop lead your so where it is
watch the angle that I have I'm going to
just pick get up and watch what you're
going to feel you feel it I'm pushing on
it okay so instead of doing this but
this is not strong cuz it's too vertical
I want that 45 okay I don't want to be
here see if I if I go
90 then I can stand up and you don't
feel it but I'm
90 so I have to be under on the 45 so I
have to lower and that comes around CL
clap it off
okay so I stay with her sword the
pressure okay I have to stay with that
pressure the harder you push the faster
my sword's coming
back one
[Music]
two so let's Play It Again the harder
you push the faster my sword is coming
back what do you think you should do
okay how about I just tell you when I'm
talking don't push
fast right one
two
boom one two
boom one two boom
okay on these movements you don't turn
your body
back you you take pressure off with the
front foot how far right how far this
this foot goes and then the front foot
moves off that's that's where you take
the pressure off you're not going to
turn the fight over here and then you
come back you never take the weapon out
of between you and your opponent you the
weapon stays with
him you don't don't seek your tension
free movement by taking your tension
moving it on a circle and then coming
back you release the whole
shoulder as it comes in boom okay and it
doesn't change he pushes right it
doesn't change on this one too I don't
go here and then back
in the weapon is Boom here boom okay try
it
again
for e
when he pushes we'll just have you push
okay my hands are going to stay in front
of me okay they not going to go over
here I hands stay in front of me you
see he pushes I feel the weight okay my
hand stay in front of me that's the
first thing I want you to look at my
hand stays in front of
me all right now I want you to look at
the hands go slow look at the hands and
tell yourself what's what's actually
happening let's start with the first
part of the
turn let's moving
your left hand the left hand is moving
okay it's going to hit what line on my
body the Y Line the the is it the Y Line
which Chris midline the midline you see
that now it's done if it went past the
midline the sword moved away from me yes
so it hits the midline and now what do
you see the other hand is Tak the other
hand is taken over and this left hand
stays on the
midline
okay
see you see that difference
yes you can see the
tension this makes
tension tension
flid okay try it again as I said before
we'll just do when he pushes here I go
into that stance right to keep the angle
of incidence on the weapon without
pressure so I going in that stance to
lower myself pop
and on the next
one uh say you do it
he comes
around okay
War here I'm going to do it to check him
okay so my body
goes here and then same exact movement
[Music]
is what you
want is what you want okay got
it here all right try it again